Bonjour! Aujourd'hui on va parler de villes,
parce que même si on est 75% de français
à y vivre de nos jours ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas. Entre le Xe et le XIIIe siècle,
les urbains ne dépassait pas 15% de la population
et c'est justement à cette période qu'on
va s'intéresser.
-Clair, bref, précis, une introduction comme
on les aime.
-Je sens qu'on va encore totalement ignorer
ma période, réveillez-moi si vous avez besoin
de mon expertise.
-Alors c'est parti.
Même si le territoire français actuel s'urbanise
durant l'Antiquité romaine...
Je disais: L'ANTIQUITÉ ROMAINE.
-Lutèce!
-Entre le Ve et le XIe siècle, la plupart
des villes perdent de leur surface: Chartres
passe de 200 à 11ha, Reims de 600 à 60ha...
Les villes se retrouvent toutes trouées de
partout, avec des vignes et des champs entre
deux rues, et on construit des maisons n'importe
où sans respecter les rues antiques bien
droites.
-Les plans hippodamiens ça nous passait un
peu au dessus, bon, bon, d'accord!
-On retrouve le même schéma à Paris, dont
les habitants durant le Bas Empire romain
s'étaient étendus de l'île de la Cité
vers la rive gauche mais se retranchent bien
derrière les remparts de l'île de la Cité
à partir des «invasions barbares» puis
des raids vikings.
-*citation latine sur les barbares*
D'autres villes subissent en plus des épidémies,
ce qui n'arrange pas les choses.
Pendant toute cette période, la population
se répartit autour des villes ou des abbayes,
selon un mode de vie rurale inspiré des germains.
Mais à partir du XIe, ça repart!
-Et voilà, adieu l'Antiquité.
-La production agricole augmente, la France
commence à développer son commerce, et tout
ça permet un nouveau développement des villes
souvent grâce à l'intervention des seigneurs
locaux.
Seigneurs qui pouvaient être soit laïcs,
soit religieux. Certaines villes reprennent
donc à partir des anciennes villes romaines,
comme Paris, Chartres, Toulouse ou Arles dont
même l'amphithéâtre est occupé...
Mais d'autres villes médiévales se forment
autour d'abbayes, comme Conques, ou autour
de mottes castrales, comme Castelnau, Neufchâteau...
Et c'est pratique parce qu'il y a le mot «château»
dans leur nom.
Ou encore, des grandes villes médiévales
comme Tours, Arras, Montpellier... Sont à
la base polynucléaires et se forment par
la réunion progressive de tout ce qu'on trouvait
dans le coin: églises, abbayes, châteaux,
etc. Par exemple, à Paris au XIVe, 80% de
la surface de la ville est possédée par
des ecclésiastiques contre 10% par le roi
et le reste par des petits seigneurs, parce
que la ville est formée par beaucoup de monastères
inclus au fur et à mesure dans son territoire.
Dès le XIIe-XIIIe siècle, les villes reprennent
leur taille antique et continuent de se développer
grâce à l'apparition de tavernes, d'artisanat,
et grâce à l'exode rural. Elles se dotent
de cathédrales, de maisons en pierre, et
d'enceintes pour protéger le tout.
-La démographie EXPLOSE.
-D'ailleurs, parlons de la population: les
seuls documents qui nous permettent de dénombrer
les habitants des villes sont les documents
fiscaux, qui apparaissent au début du XIVe
siècle, mais ils comptent les feux et non
les personnes.
-Les feux, c'est les foyers.
-C'est chaud.
-Comme il y a sûrement 4 à 5 personnes par
feu, ça nous permet de savoir que les plus
petites villes comme le Mans ou Annecy ont
2-3000 habitants, les villes moyennes comme
Marseille en ont 10 000, et les grandes villes
comme Lyon, Lille ou Toulouse en comptent
entre 20 000 et 40 000. Les plus grandes villes
d'Europe se trouvent en Flandre et en Italie,
grâce à leur importante production de textile,
et Paris est la grande exception avec 250
000 habitants dès le début du XIVe.
Mais laissons de côté les chiffres quelques
instants pour parler un peu de la vie en ville.
Un proverbe allemand du XVe dit que «l'air
de la ville rend libre». A la différence
de la campagne où la population est généralement
asservie, on pense que la ville permet plus
de libertés voire peut-être l'ascension
sociale. Il existe donc un «esprit de la
ville», les gens son fiers d'être urbains.
Les villes sont des espaces de culture, aussi,
puisque c'est là que la plupart des fables
et fabliaux sont écrits.
-Dans un fabliau du XIIIe, on retrouve par
exemple l'histoire d'un paysan qui vient pour
la première fois à Paris et perd sa femme
sur le petit-pont tellement il y a de monde.
Et tellement il y a de monde qu'il rentre
au village avec une autre, parce que pourquoi
pas.
-Généralement, les citadins sont mieux mis
en valeur dans les fabliaux que les paysans
qui sont décrits comme un peu idiots.
Les villes sont aussi un peu plus à l'abri
des famines que les campagnes, ce qui en fait
d'office des espaces d'abondance, et de sécurité
grâce à leurs enceintes qui sont fermées
la nuit: une cloche annonce leur ouverture
le matin. A ce moment là entrent les laitières
venues vendre leur lait dans les rues, accompagnées
de nombreux autres crieurs issus de la ville
ou de la campagne qui proposent du vin, des
légumes, etc.
-Il existait aussi des crieurs qui annonçaient
l'ouverture des bains publics, puisque très
rares étaient ceux qui avaient de quoi se
laver chez eux.
-Ah bon, vous vous laviez?
-En plus des crieurs on peut entendre des
cloches, qui rythment la journée, le bruit
des différents artisans qui travaillent dans
leur boutique ou qui sont venus installer
leur table pliante là où il y avait de la
place, les montreurs d'ours ou de singes,
les animaux de toutes sortes, les processions
qui fêtent les différents saints, des membres
d'ordres mendiants qui prêchent sur les places
et dans les églises... Et puis des événements
un peu plus exceptionnels comme les kermesses,
carnavals, ou les entrées royales.
-Les rues des villes sont étroites, elles
font 10 à 12 mètres au plus large et sont
rarement pavées. Au XIVe, il n'existe pas
de différence entre les quartiers, on peut
trouver un hôtel particulier à côté de
petites maisons qui sont souvent en bois et
recouvertes d'enduit.
-Comme la plupart des maisons n'ont pas de
latrines, on trouve des latrines publiques
un peu partout qui ont laissé leur marque
dans la toponymie: par exemple, il existe
une ruelle du Pipi à Châlons sur Marne,
et je pense que ses habitants peuvent être
fiers de cet héritage.
Les plus riches ont quand même des latrines
chez eux qui se déversent ensuite dans la
rue grâce à des conduits, puis s'écoulent
par le caniveau central dans lequel on évite
de marcher.
-D'ailleurs, si les rues sont un peu trop
remplies, on s'emmerde. Littéralement.
-Je pensais pas aborder un tel sujet un jour.
Et puis quand vient le soir, les bougies sont
interdites à cause des risques d'incendies,
alors une cloche annonce la fermeture des
portes de la ville et tout le monde va se
coucher.
Ça va être tout noir !
-Bien sûr le développement des villes nécessite
un peu d'organisation.
Au départ, les villes sont sous la juridiction
de celui qui en possède les terres, le seigneur,
qu'il soit religieux ou laïc, mais dès le
XIIe siècle elles réclament plus d'autonomie
et obtiennent des documents qui la leur accordent.
Le but est aussi de se débarrasser de toutes
les taxes imposées par les seigneurs et qui
gênent le développement économique des
villes.
-Ces documents sont appelés chartes communales,
ou bien chartes de franchise au Nord ou chartes
consulaires au Sud.
-J'ai connu un consul...
-Rien à voir. Ces chartes concernent les
bourgeois, c'est à dire ceux qui ont ce statut
parce qu'ils vivent en ville depuis plus d'un
an, ou qu'ils possèdent une maison en ville,
ça peut varier.
Parmi eux est choisi un groupe de personnes,
nommé échevins au Nord et consuls ou capitouls
au Sud, qui dirigent la ville. Ils ont le
pouvoir de rendre la justice, d'établir les
impôts, de lever des milices, etc.
La première charte est signée au Mans en
1070, et la plus ancienne conservée date
de 1112 pour la ville de Lorris.
L'autonomie des villes est une question importante
et qui fâche: en 1112, l'évêque Gaudry
qui était seigneur de Laon est assassiné
car il refuse d'accorder une charte communale
aux bourgeois de sa ville. De manière générale,
l’Église tente davantage de résister à
cette émancipation des villes que les seigneurs
laïcs.
Dans les chartes, on retrouve aussi certaines
mesures telles que l'affranchissement d'un
serf qui aurait passé un an dans la ville
sans être réclamé par son seigneur. Comme
quoi l'air de la ville rend parfois vraiment
libre.
Les conseils d'échevins ou de consuls forment
donc petit à petit des conseils municipaux,
dirigés par des maires souvent élus pour
un an. Ils sont choisis par les notables de
la ville, des marchands ou juristes par exemple,
ce qui en fait un système plutôt oligarchique.
-Quand ce sont les huiles qui dirigent.
-Les séances peuvent se tenir dans des beffrois
ou des hôtels de ville, ou parfois dans de
simples maisons quand il n'y a pas d'autre
endroit.
Paris constitue une exception sur laquelle
on reviendra un peu plus tard puisque c'est
un corps de métier en particulier, la hanse
des marchands de l'eau, qui administre la
ville à partir de 1260.
Auparavant, elle a déjà la particularité
d'être la ville qui cumule le plus de fonctions:
-Économique, grâce au commerce et à la
production artisanale. C'était déjà le
cas à mon époque.
-Religieuse, puisqu'elle est siège d'évêché
et comprend de nombreux monastères.
-Universitaire, à partir du XIIe siècle
avec l'installation d'une école près de
la cathédrale puis de l'Université au XIIIe.
-Et enfin, politique, parce que le roi.
-Dès le VIe siècle Paris était la capitale
de Clovis mais il n'y résidait pas et n'y
gouvernait pas. Elle est remplacée par Aix-la-Chapelle
sous les carolingiens, mais redevient importante
à partir du Xe siècle et surtout sous le
roi Philippe Auguste.
-Au XIIe siècle, il décide de transférer
à Paris son trésor et ses archives, ce qui
en fait sa capitale administrative. Il fait
aussi construire une enceinte en 1190, et
les rois de France y résident de plus en
plus à partir du XIIIe siècle parce que
c'est joli.
-Au XIVe siècle, les services fiscaux s'y
installent aussi. La présence du roi et de
sa cour, ainsi que de plus en plus d'officiers
royaux, stimule encore plus l'économie de
la ville, bref, c'est tout bénéf pour Paris.
En plus de s'installer à Paris, les rois
de France cherchent à reprendre le contrôle
sur les privilèges des autres villes: lorsqu'ils
rentrent dans une ville, la cérémonie veut
que les bourgeois leur remettent leur charte
communale pour qu'ils la leur ré-accordent
en leur nom.
-Alors qu'ils avaient absolument rien à voir
avec tout ça.
-Philippe Auguste accorde aussi des chartes
communales aux villes qui se trouvent sur
le domaine royal. Par la suite, le pouvoir
des villes décline à partir du XVIe siècle,
avec l'émergence de l'absolutisme.
Comme on l'a déjà un peu mentionné, en
ville, on ne trouve pas que de la ville mais
parfois des champs, des jardins, des animaux
etc. L'archéologie nous permet de retrouver
ces espaces non occupés puisqu'on y trouve
de la «terre noire», une terre sur laquelle
rien n'a été bâti.
-De la même manière, tu sais comment on
appelle une mer qui n'a jamais été occupée?
-Non, mais ça n'a pas vraiment de sens...
-C'est la mer noire
-Au fur et à mesure que les villes grossissent,
l'accès à de la nourriture fraîche devient
par contre plus difficile et nécessite la
mise en place d'un circuit économique.
Déjà, on fait sécher certains produits
pour les conserver plus longtemps, comme les
fruits, ou bien on les plonge dans le miel
ou le vinaigre, on sale les jambons...
On importe du blé, du vin, de la viande,
du poisson, parfois de très loin puisque
Venise importe du blé bulgare, la France
achète des produits hongrois, etc.
-Avec les importations apparaissent des appellations,
dès le XIIIe siècle, comme les pâtés de
Paris, la moutarde de Dijon ou le maroilles
de... Maroilles.
Des halles se créent pour accueillir les
marchés, qui sont encore libres au Xe siècle:
les autorités n'interviennent que pour contrôler
la marchandise, vérifier que le vin n'est
pas coupé avec de l'eau par exemple, mais
chaque métier a sa propre juridiction et
se gère tout seul. Jusqu'en 1183, du moins,
où Philippe Auguste met en place les premières
réglementations du marché.
Avant ça, comme je l'ai dit, chaque métier
avait sa propre juridiction. On appelait ce
système les corporations, des groupes de
métiers aussi parfois appelés guildes, confréries,
hanses... Qui décidaient des droits et des
devoirs souvent stricts des gens du métier
dans la ville, et constituaient aussi une
caisse commune au cas où un membre tomberait
malade ou mourrait.
-Solidaires!
-Les compétences des membres de ces corporations
allaient plus loin puisqu'ils devaient aussi
assurer le guet de la ville, la lutte contre
les incendies ou encore l'entretien des remparts.
Un artisan était d'abord apprenti, durant
plusieurs années, puis devenait compagnon,
et pouvait passer maître par la suite, ce
qui lui permettait d'ouvrir sa propre boutique
et de prendre à son tour des apprentis.
L'existence de ces corporations permet de
connaître les métiers présents dans les
villes, puisqu'en 1268 le roi Louis IX charge
Etienne Boileau de lister toutes les corporations
de Paris. On constate alors qu'il existe près
de 900 métiers différents, ayant chacun
des statuts de métier qui réglementent aussi
le travail des femmes d'artisans, par exemple,
qui exerçaient souvent le même métier que
leur mari mais ne pouvaient pas devenir maîtres.
Elles ne pouvaient pas non plus prendre d'apprenti
à la mort de leur mari, parce qu'elles n'étaient
pas estimées assez capables.
Cependant, beaucoup de statuts emploient des
termes mixtes pour désigner les artisans,
comme «celles et ceux», et ça fait
plutôt plaisir.
En opposition à ces groupes stricts émergent
aussi à partir du XIIe siècle les compagnons:
ce sont des ouvriers qui préfèrent rester
itinérants pour échapper à toutes ces règles.
Ils sont plutôt clandestins, alors ils se
réunissent dans des auberges et se reconnaissent
grâce à des signes secrets.
-Comment est vostre soupe?
-Ma soupe est bonne ?
Tous ces artisans peuvent vendre leurs produits
dans leurs boutiques mais aussi lors de foires,
et l'une des plus réputées est celle de
Provins. Elle appartient aux comtes de Champagne,
dont la région est très réputée pour sa
production de laine et ses villes marchandes.
A la différence d'un banal marché, les foires
attirent des marchands de très loin, d'Italie
ou de Flandres, qui vendent souvent des produits
venant d'encore plus loin.
-Les foires de Champagne, c'est LE rassemblement
de l'année, dès le XIe siècle. Les rassemblement,
même, puisqu'il y en a une en mai et une
à l'automne.
-Elles durent 46 jours et on y trouvait jusque
40 000 personnes. Leur essor est permis par
les comtes de Champagne qui sécurisent les
voies, organisent des convois, assurent la
sécurité des marchands...
Elles entraînent un formidable essor de cette
région, à tel point que le denier provinois,
la monnaie locale, devient une monnaie de
référence dans toute l'Europe.
Petit à petit des bâtiments spécialisés
se créent, comme des granges ou des maisons
de commerce que les marchands louaient le
temps de la foire. Le commerce évolue aussi,
puisqu'à partir de 1250 les marchands ne
voyagent plus avec du liquide mais avec des
lettres de change, les foires se doublent
donc de centres financiers avec des changeurs
pour transformer le tout en argent.
Ces foires déclinent néanmoins dans la 2e
moitié du XIIIe siècle, à cause du développement
des routes terrestres à travers les Alpes
et du transport fluvial, grâce auquel Paris
dépasse les foires de Provins.
-De toute façon j'étais plus pro-hydromel.
Et pour terminer, on va s'intéresser aux
habitants. Beaucoup d'habitants des villes
sont d'anciens ruraux, qui ont tendance à
se regrouper par origine géographique. On
retrouve leur origine dans leur nom, qui peut
devenir par exemple Le Normand, Le Breton...
Ils peuvent venir de loin ou des villages
alentours, mais restent considérés comme
moins honorables que les «anciens» et
partir vivre en ville n'efface pas non plus
les rumeurs qui pouvaient exister sur eux,
les nouvelles vont vite.
On pense que les étrangers représentent
20 à 30% de la population des villes qu'ils
soient là durablement ou de passage comme
des marchands étudiants, mercenaires, courtisans,
compagnons...
Selon les époques et les lieux, les dirigeants
encouragent l'immigration et l'insertion de
ces personnes en leur donnant leur protection,
par exemple pour repeupler la ville après
une épidémie, ou la découragent si la situation
économique est mauvaise. Dans certaines villes
les étrangers sont rassemblés par quartiers
ou mis en marge, alors que d'autres comme
Venise refusent que les étrangers aient des
quartiers réservés pour faciliter leur intégration.
En tout cas, comme à beaucoup d'époques,
on leur réserve plutôt les métiers pénibles
dont personne ne veut et certains s'organisent
en confréries d'étrangers pour accueillir
les nouveaux venus et pratiquer leurs fêtes
locales.
On trouve aussi beaucoup de pauvres en ville:
au Moyen Âge, cette expression ne désigne
pas seulement ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup
d'argent mais aussi les faibles, les malades,
les trop jeunes, trop vieux, trop étrangers,
etc. Mais souvent, toutes ces différences
font qu'ils sont pauvres au sens propre aussi.
Selon les villes, 70 à 85% de la population
est trop pauvre pour paye l'impôt: on les
appelle les nichils, du latin nihil «rien».
Mais comme on s'intéresse peu à eu, on manque
de sources à leur sujet.
Et enfin, il y avait les bourgeois. A la base
ce terme désigne juste les habitants du bourg,
mais à partir du XIIe siècle il évolue
pour désigner les citadins les plus privilégiés.
A partir du XIVe siècle, par exemple, les
parisiens les plus notables se désignent
comme «bourgeois de Paris»: il existe
des rues à leur nom, parce qu'ils sont parmi
les premiers à prendre un nom de famille
en plus du prénom, et ils adoptent même
des armoiries. Ce groupe représente environ
25% des parisiens, et parmi eux les 1% les
plus riches paient 80% des impôts. Ce sont
souvent des marchands liés au commerce de
luxe et qui vendent un peu de tout, mais aussi
des rentiers qui vivent des maisons qu'ils
possèdent.
-Leur statut s'accompagne de pas mal de privilèges
sympathiques: ils bénéficient de la protection
royale dans tout le royaume, puisque leur
seigneur est juste le roi de France, ils sont
exemptés du droit de gîte qui veut que le
roi et sa cour peuvent réquisitionner n'importe
quelle demeure, et peuvent saisir les biens
parisiens de leurs débiteurs.
-Leur mode de vie se rapproche de celui de
la cour, dont ils partagent les loisirs, mais
ils ne sont pas attirés par la noblesse car
leur propre statut est déjà pas mal du tout
comme on vient de le voir. Ils restent aussi
beaucoup entre eux, au sein de la famille,
parce que la coutume veut qu'un enfant qui
quitterait le foyer recevrait alors directement
sa part de l'héritage donc dans des familles
commerçantes où la fortune ne fait que grimper
autant rester jusqu'au bout.
-Solidaires!
On trouve certains de ces bourgeois à des
postes importants, dans l'Hôtel du Roi par
exemple, et ils se rangent toujours de son
côté lors des révoltes urbaines.
A partir de 1170, ces bourgeois de Paris obtiennent
des fonctions encore plus importantes: Louis
VII accorde à la corporation des marchands
d'eau le monopole du commerce sur la Seine
entre les ponts de Paris et de Mantes, contre
50% des revenus issus des amendes qu'ils ont
le droit de dresser. A partir de là, cette
corporation devient un peu toute puissante
et un marchand étranger qui voudrait commercer
à Paris doit s'associer avec eux.
A partir de 1260, cette hanse des marchands
d'eau se transforme en municipalité: ce
sont donc ces bourgeois là qui ont les fonctions
politiques telles que paver les rues, entretenir
les remparts, approvisionner la ville, assurer
le guet, lever l'impôt...
Tout comme les échevins qui dirigent les
grandes villes au détriment du seigneur,
les marchands de Paris occupent donc une place
de plus en plus importante par rapport au
roi qui leur délègue une partie du boulot.
L'épisode le plus long de la chaîne s'achève
donc, et j'aurais encore pu parler des universités
présentes dans certaines villes mais auxquelles
j'accorderai plutôt une vidéo à part tellement
il y avait à dire.
On se retrouve le mois prochain, donc, pour
un autre Chroniques de Prof si tout va bien
et je tiens à remercier toutes les personnes
qui ont participé à la campagne Ulule et
qui nous ont permis de récolter suffisamment
pour faire une belle série en plus des Chroniques
de Prof. Youpi. Il reste d'ailleurs quelques
jours avant la clôture de la campagne donc
je vous remet le lien à la fin de la vidéo
et en commentaire, c'est le dernier moment
pour partager ou donner.
-We need you!
-Et en attendant la prochaine vidéo: aurevoir.